we have major news today in regards to
Matt Reeves as the Batman how's it going
everybody it's Warren and if you haven't
tuned in to my channel in a while don't
worry Marvel content of course is still
here
in fact I'm making more Marvel content
than ever introducing top fives top 10s
lore and comic breakdowns as well and of
course I will always try to get the news
out as fast as I can
but for those of you who do not know and
for those of you who are new to my
channel I am starting to introduce DC
and Star Wars content to my channel
because there is a lot of exciting
things happening within the superhero
world
keypoint today it has been announced
that zoe kravitz has officially been
cast as Catwoman in the upcoming the
Batman movie before we dive into it a
reminder to subscribe to my channel so
you can enter my giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox one or a ps4 and be sure
to drop a like and a comment as well
so today Variety reported that actress
zoe kravitz has officially landed the
role as Catwoman in the upcoming film
the Batman she'll be starring opposite
of Robert Pattinson who of course has
been casted as the Batman zoe kravitz is
actually making a jump from Marvel not
the MCU but marvel over to the DC
Universe now it's actually not the first
time that she did this she starred as
angel in x-men first class in 2011 and
then was in the Lego Batman movie in
2017 where she actually voiced Catwoman
but then she actually made her way to
the spider-verse with Sony in spider-man
into the spider verse where she voiced
Mary Jane now it's been said that the
Batman is supposed to have many iconic
characters from Batman in the movie and
Catwoman is obviously one of the most
iconic Batman characters there is now
sometimes Catwoman is a friend of
Batman's and sometimes she's a villain
and sometimes she's a love interest as
of right now it's unclear of what her
story is going to be in the Batman but
we know that the Batman is going to have
many villains in the film it's been
reported at one point in time that the
film will have five villains in it and
right now Jonah Hill is in talks to
either be playing the role of penguin or
the Riddler now this is going to be sort
of a revamp of Batman that's why we have
Robert Pattinson playing the role
because it's going to be a younger
Batman so the whole cast is going to be
a bit younger than we're used to with
the exception of probably characters
like Detective Gordon but Jonah Hill and
zoe kravitz fit right
alongside with Robert Pattinson there
are still a lot more villains to be
revealed for this movie and it is still
unclear whether or not Catwoman is
actually going to be a villain or not
and will there be a love interest
between Catwoman and Batman in this film
be sure to let me know what you think
about this in the comments down below do
you think that Catwoman is going to be a
villain or a friend to Batman and do you
think there's going to be some sort of a
relationship between Batman and Catwoman
in the film let me know your thoughts
and let me know how excited you are in
the comments down below be sure to check
out the spider-man and venom video I did
earlier on today and be sure to
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to the
DC EU and the MCU and so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or a ps4 be sure to follow me on
Twitter and Instagram as well I'll be
starting some giveaways very soon and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof